welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss in The Flash release one final
trailer ahead of its June release in my
oh my to the visuals of this movie look
so good aside from an uninspired Desert
location that I think just really only
looks so so by comparison to everything
else let's break down this footage shot
by shot because while a lot of it is
stuff that we have seen before there are
quite a few new interesting Easter eggs
and details that you might have missed
now we are close enough to the movie
that I'm gonna avoid just trying to
piece together the whole plot of the
movie or retread over shots that I've
talked about in past breakdowns just
gonna be laser focused on the new stuff
also please grab one of our Miles
Morales Multiverse dive shirts over at
nerd riot.shop and subscribe to the Deep
dive Channel where I did a thorough
analysis of the 1989 Michael gean Batman
film which I gotta say is required
viewing before we head into this Flash
movie
let's get nuts okay this final trailer
opens with Barry Allen getting
recognized by fans these kids are
covered in Flash pins and it happens to
be in front of a bilby's cafe which
might be a reference to the character
named Bilby in The Time Machine by H.G
Wells really the first fictional work
that you could say popularized the
concept of time travel and judged by
that flag on the door Philly has made
his Cafe a safe space Jeremy Irons
returns as the DC EU Alfred pennyworth
and Bruce Wayne's Hangar on Alfred
screens is a schematic of Batman's
motorcycle with a map of the city in
front of him so basically Alfred's
running point on whatever this Chase
mission that Batman's involved with and
Gotham that he needs Barry's help with
Barry's eyed pieces drop down and you
can definitely see a glowing heads-up
display interface inside those goggles
which practically must have to move fast
enough buffering wise to keep up with
Barry Speed to be able to navigate him
so even his technology has to be as fast
as he is because you know if it was just
like Google Maps or Waze in there Barry
would totally outrun how slow that crap
is because when it's me and I like off
on an exit it takes it like a solid 10
seconds to just know where I am and with
my ability to drive and navigate it's
like in the middle of a lake I love the
street stretching into this kind of
hyperspace as he's about to take off the
pavement around Barry's foot though
stays is in place only the parts
illuminated in Yellow by a speed force
which seems to be the trigger that kicks
them forward if you go through this
slingshot effect frame by frame Barry's
first lunge motion keeps him in the air
as he continues to speed forward so that
really in a single stride he moves an
entire city block Perry explains to
benap like Bruce Wayne the disability to
go back in time would allow him to
change things including saving Bruce's
parents now does this mean we might get
a flashback too when it was Jeopardy
Morgan I mean it'd be pretty sick for
him to show up here but remember this
Ben act like Bruce Wayne must know that
Barry will have traveled through time at
some point because of Batman v Superman
Barry visited Bruce threw a portal to
tell him that Lois Lane was the key so
this is why he doesn't completely stop
him from going back in time because he
knows that's just part of fate and part
of Destiny but he doesn't say while
you're running through everything just
you know leave that movie screening as
is because I like being Batman so the
narrowberry tumbles into this timeline
where his mother Nora is still alive and
his father Henry is not in jail or
killing her we see Barry chowing down on
Spaghetti because as he told Bruce in
Justice League he needs to carve about
load to restore his energy then our
berry sees this timeline's Berry doing
the goofiest dance Walk ever in the
streets carrying what looks like a sack
of laundry I don't know why alternate
Berry would be in the front yard based
on where he was walking but you know the
grass makes the tackle softer now in the
bedroom before I pointed out the posters
for the other Warner Brothers films like
Pacific Rim but now in the upper left
corner there is a poster for Christopher
Nolan's bong Inception another movie
that I just broke down on the Deep dive
and I love this because while Nolan made
Inception with Warner Brothers in 2010
Nolan angrily parted ways with that
studio over Warner's decision to release
its 2021 films on streaming Nolan is now
releasing Oppenheimer with universal but
the flash was shot pre-pandemic when
Nolan was still a Warner guy now the
music over this trailer is Pink Floyd's
time from Dark Side of the Moon a song
that also opened Marvel's eternals it's
one of my favorite classic rock tracks
and I always love hearing it and while
the lyrics totally apply to what Barry
is going through thematically kicking
around on a piece of ground in your
hometown feeling like time has passed in
by I've never really felt like like
tonally the Rock chords of the song have
matched any of these superhero films
maybe it's just because for me the music
on its own creates a cinematic image in
one's head it kind of feels like it just
sort of cheapens the song to make it the
soundtrack needle drop but I guess as I
get older I just kind of feel that way
about most rock songs that are used in
movies like leave radiohead's creep
added Guardians volume 3. I realize I'm
now an old man yelling at clouds or
maybe I'm just a speaker in Pink Floyd's
time but whatever I do love hearing the
song and I will say it's really cool how
this trailer sinks the editing to
kicking around on a piece of ground with
Kara stomping and kicking side
geology is a 22 time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognizing
Men's Health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ their products are
built around just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have been
trusted by dermatologists for decades
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you geologists
co-wash and their deodorant are just so
great and I use them all the time right
now they're offering a special offer for
a skincare sampler pack and geology
skincare stuff is in a league of its own
geology's line of skin care products can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging there's never
been a better time to try geology than
right now for a limited time use code
rockstars100 to get 100 off your
personalized 30 days skincare sampler
set all you have to cover is the 495 for
shipping what a deal on top of that new
Rockstar's fans get an exclusive bonus
offer of up to 50 off on an additional
skin hair and body a product of your
choice when you add it to your trial
click the link in the description or go
to
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started Barry tells the alternate
Berry it's not Clark before Clark's
Kryptonian cousin Kara zorel introduces
herself and Bruce Wayne offers his help
too I want to know who he's saying it's
not Clark too because these characters
wouldn't really know of any Clark but
maybe when they broke in that facility
they thought they were getting Clark out
of there but found his cousin instead
you'll notice how alternate Berry is
suited up in one of Bruce's old bat
suits painting part of it red with the
yellow lightning bolt icon this suit up
seems to happen after they rescue Kara
from that remote facility which then
would lead to the four Heroes working
together to stop Zod in this alternate
timeline where there was no call-el to
stop him from terraforming Earth in the
events of Man of Steel and yes I did
break down these seven bat suits in the
past trailers but I just love that the
third on the left remains scarred from
the events of that 1989 film from
Batman's fight with the Jack Nicholson
Joker there's a great shot of Barry in
the alternate berries twin speed force
is emanating now from the two of them
boot to boot one blue one golden I don't
know why it's a different color other
than just the practicality in this movie
to tell the two of them apart but later
in the trailer it looks like we see what
happens right after this the two berries
combining their forces to speed in the
opposite direction to attack zod's
forces we see Kara punching through a
missile and I love how whether it's this
Warhead or zod's face whenever she
punches bends and smushes briefly before
exploding like in The Matrix when that
helicopter Smashes in the building
remember and the glass just kind of
undulated looked awesome pick my
favorite shot in this trailer it's just
this clip of Ben Affleck Batman it's
getting along the bridge it's cable
slicing off the side of the roof of that
taxi and then he gets to his feet and he
runs up the hood of the car into a leap
where the cape expands The Wider shot
you see how Batman on the motorcycle is
chasing that armored truck they're going
with the flow of traffic now though he
has swung over the left side of the
bridge where he's facing oncoming
traffic then shot a Bruce on his
motorcycle with kids deboarding a school
bus ahead so he has to turn into a skid
to Swerve into the Plaza on the left the
trailer ends with this clip
we have fancy friends
yo who's an Uber
exact so in this alley in Central City I
assume there's a sign that says whiz
this is it which could be an odd two
whiz with onesie Comics a label that
published the early Captain Marvel
Shazam comics when it was under faucet
Publications and across the street
there's a barber shop that looks like
Grayson's as in Dick Grayson and his
family remember there was that defaced
Robin suit that Zack Snyder put in the
Batcave in Batman v Superman many
thought that this was meant to be Jason
Todd but Zack Snyder confirmed on Bureau
in November 2018 that his plan was for
this Robin to be Dick Grayson so if that
continuity Remains the case for this
movie there could be some other relative
of the late Dick Grayson who runs
Barbershop hey reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and
supported us by grabbing some merch at
nerdright.shop also subscribe to our new
channel the break room follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
the new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]